herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
in tschechien ganz nah an der
tschechisch bayerischen grenze hat es
heute morgen gegen 8 uhr ein schweres
zugunglück gegeben
der alex expresszug ix 351 war auf dem
weg von münchen nach prag der
tschechische regionalzug war auf dem weg
von pilsen nach dollar schlitze in der
nähe des vinzenz bieler auf der
eingleisigen strecke krachen die beiden
züge ineinander die bilder der völlig
zerfetzten lokführer stände lassen es
sofort erahnen die beiden lokführer
hatten keine chance sie starten und auch
eine weitere reisende bevor wir mit
unseren reportern sprechen über das
unglück über die lager über die zahl der
toten und verletzten
und auch darüber wie geholfen wird die
möglichen ursachen eine zusammenfassung
dass dessen was wir bisher wissen es ist
kurz nach acht uhr heute morgen als die
beiden züge kurz hinter der
bayerisch-tschechischen grenze
zusammenstoßen
der expresszug münchen prag hatte nach
angaben des tschechischen
verkehrsministers ein haltesignal
überfahren
die situation ist ernst zurzeit sieht
alles danach aus dass der fahrer des
expresszuges aus münchen nicht auf das
gelbe signal geachtet hat nicht
langsamer gefahren ist und dann auch
nicht auf das stoppschild reagiert hat
und ist somit dem anderen zug kollidiert
das unglück ereignete sich bei dem lied
der expresszug aus deutschland war auf
dem weg nach prag
unter den toten sollen die beiden
lokführer sein der zug aus münchen wurde
von einem privaten anbieter betrieben
der bayerischen länder bahn alex am
unglücksort sind rettungsdienste aus
tschechien und deutschland im einsatz
auf tschechischen bahn strecken kommt es
immer wieder zu unfällen
die sicherheitstechnik gilt vielerorts
als veraltet erst vor einem jahr waren
im erzgebirge nahe der deutschen grenze
zwei züge frontal zusammengestoßen
zwei menschen starben
meine kollegin unserer reporterin jutta
sonne wald ist direkt am unglücksort in
mihla fft juta welches bild bietet sich
dir da es ist ein ziemlich furchtbares
bild man sieht die zwei verkeilten züge
man sieht sie hinter uns die menschen
wurden inzwischen alle geborgen aus den
zügen wir als wir angekommen sind war
das noch nicht sicher da hat man hier
auch noch einsatzkräfte gesehen mit
großen sägen und kettensägen die auch
noch hier gearbeitet haben inzwischen
ist bestätigt worden alle menschen
wurden geborgen
die zahl der toten ist auch inzwischen
klar sind drei tote eben die beiden
lokführer wie wir im bericht gehört
haben und auch eine frau aus dem
tschechischen zug und viele
schwerverletzte
es heißt gerade eben ganz frisch nochmal
vier menschen sind noch einmal in einem
kritischen zustand das war vorhin nicht
ganz so kritisch aber vier menschen sind
noch nicht wieder im kritischen zustand
utah wo sind denn die menschen wo sind
denn die verletzten hingebracht worden
das unglück ist ja nun nahe an der
deutsch tschechischen grenze sind denn
auch deutsche helfer im einsatz sind
verletzte auch nach deutschland gebracht
worden
ja das ist wirklich einmalig innerhalb
von 25 minuten waren die rettungskräfte
aus bayern her und zwar ist es ein
wirklich gut eingespieltes system was
ich schon seit jahren bewährt hat seit
2016 arbeiten hier die das bayerische
rote kreuz arbeitet hier mit den
tschechischen einsatzkräften zusammen
immer wieder in notlagen so dass es hier
grenzübergreifend ganz schnell hilfe
geben kann
es ist also so dass man keine
sprachgrenzen hat weil die bayerischen
einsatzkräfte auch tschechisch können
und weil man immer eingespielt ist und
auch immer übungs manöver zusammen macht
ist auch sozusagen die einsatztaktik
bekannten bekannt dass heißt es war
innerhalb von 25 minuten waren die
einsatzkräfte vor ort
es gab zehn verletzte deutsche die
wurden auch in deutsche krankenhäuser
ausgeflogen und zwar wurden welche
nachkam ausgeflogen und es wurden auch
welchen eine eine person wurde nach
regensburg geflogen und zwei kamen nach
schwandorf in die klinik diese zehn
deutschen verletzten von denen weiß man
sie sind nicht schwer verletzt also
unter den schwerverletzten sind
tschechische schwerverletzte das heißt
utah du sprichst von hubschraubern das
heißt ist das so gut so schnell
koordiniert worden dass also nicht nur
rettungswagen die haben sie gerade im
hintergrund gesehen sondern eben auch
hubschrauber vor ort waren genau 1 1 ein
hubschrauber aus regensburg von dem es
ganz bekannt dass er hier war insgesamt
heißt es werden vier hubschrauber im
einsatz gewesen und auch 10
rettungswagen und zwei notärzte als es
dann wirklich enorm viele einsatzkräfte
aus deutschland hier die soforthilfe
geleistet haben und auch jetzt noch hier
im anliegenden also paar hundert meter
von uns entfernt ist so eine art
kulturzentrum haben sie auch sofort eine
psychologische beratungsstelle
eingerichtet dort werden auch noch die
leicht verletzten betreut und beraten
also das ist wirklich das lief wie am
schnürchen das kann man sagen ist
wirklich exzellent gewesen was wissen
wir denn über die fahrgäste an bord der
beiden züge wird lesen aus tschechischen
medien an bord des deutschen zuges von
münchen nach prag sollen auch sehr viele
ausländische deutsche ausländische gäste
und eben auch deutsche gewesen sein also
über die insassen kann ich nichts sagen
diese zahl dazu kann ich einfach nicht
sagen da weiß ich nichts dazu aber du
hast es eben gesagt deutsche und
tschechische fahrgäste eben auf jeden
fall werde die sind denn jetzt weiß
schon genau was man was man auch weiß ja
eine sache weiß man eben noch dass
vielleicht noch ein interessanter
hinweis dass der lokführer in dem alex
in dem deutschen zug in dem der
landesbahn alex das war ein
tschechischer lokführer
da ist nämlich noch kurz an der grenze
vorher an bayern 1 getauscht worden so
zu sagen
und warum er das haltesignal übersehen
hat das weiß man nicht hier ist wohl
auch in den tschechischen medien eine
diskussion jetzt auch die wieder
entbrannt ist über die lokführer denn es
gibt im vergleich zur fläche hier in
tschechien zu wenig lokführer also als
eu land betrachtet zur größe des landes
hat dass hier das größte streckennetz in
ganz europa aber vergleichsweise wenig
lokführer und diese lokführer die sind
wohl viel überfordert da ist jetzt
wieder auch eine diskussion darüber
entbrannt ob vielleicht dieser lokführer
vielleicht gemeldet war
ob es am gesundheitszustand lag wann war
sein letzter einsatz von war die letzte
schicht all diese sachen müssen jetzt
ermittelt werden
also zumindest das haben wir auch
gelesen dass eben beide lokführer
tschechische staatsangehörige sind
zumindest kann man jetzt nicht sagen da
ist jetzt ein deutscher lokführer
gewesen es hätte irgendwelche
sprachprobleme gegeben das kann es also
nicht sein da werden wir nachher noch
weiter nachfragen wie haben denn jetzt
jetzt ist das unglück in der nähe dieses
ganz ganz kleinen ortes mit after
geschehen wie haben die menschen da
reagiert gibt es da auch leute aus dem
dorf die dahin gerannt sind mit denen
ihr fleisch gesprochen habt
also das kann ich nicht beurteilen also
wo wir jetzt hier stehen und wir sind
jetzt auch erst vor einer stunde hier
angekommen das ist auch ziemlich
abgesperrt das gebiet also gerade um
ebensolche gaffer hier fern zu halten
hier gibt's den kleinen fluss der uns
trennt von der unglücksstelle von den
bahngleisen
da gehen schon ab und an mal ein paar
spaziergänger vorbei und machen auch so
handyvideos aber man kann hier nicht von
einem großen koffer geschehen sprechen
und wir haben auch mit keinen menschen
gesprochen die jetzt hier irgendwie
besonders schockiert wir sind einfach
auch ein bisschen ab vom ort muss man
sagen das ist sozusagen außerhalb des
ortes und wir stehen hier so ein
bisschen hier im an den schienen halt am
verlassen etwa 200 300 meter vom
ortskern entfernt
letzte frage du hast gesagt ganz frisch
die information es sind also alle
passagiere alle verletzten eben auch aus
den wracks aus den beiden zügen raus
geholt worden was passiert denn jetzt
weiter noch werden die züge dann
auseinandergezogen untersucht was sagen
die retter die einsatzkräfte genau die
züge müssen hier dann auch geräumt
werden die verhindern auch den ganzen
verkehr gerade in tschechien also es
gibt wohl überall staus ist es ein
kompletter verkehrs zusammenbruch hat
uns unsere tschechischen besitzerin
mitgeteilt das ist also das wesentliche
dass man die züge sozusagen von den
gleisen geräumt und natürlich auch
weiterhin untersucht auch gerade zum
beispiel diese schaltknüppel die
betätigt werden müssen um auch diese
warnsignale dann wahrzunehmen also
dieses warnsystem was hier in tschechien
jetzt gibt es seit dem letzten unglück
letzten jahr ist erneuert worden und
gilt als sehr zuverlässig aber es muss
eben eingeschaltet seien jetzt wird eben
auch überprüft werden müssen ob in dem
alex dieses system eingeschaltet war
oder warum hat dieser zugführer diese
beiden warnsignale ein oranges licht und
ein altes schild ein stoppschild
übersehen
also die unglücksursache wird weiter
erforscht dann sagen wir erstmal vielen
dank für diese schilderung für die
informationen und eindrücke jutta sonne
wald in bila fischer vielen vielen dank
der chef der geschäftsführer der
bayerischen länder bahn der
betreibergesellschaft also dieses alex
express express zuges auf dem weg von
münchen nach prag hat sich gemeldet hat
gesagt es sind schreckliche bilder die
uns aus tschechien erreichen
wir sind in gedanken bei den opfern
dieses schlimmen zugunglücks so wolfgang
poletti der länder waren geschäftsführer
vor ort wird alles getan um zu helfen
wir unterstützen
die tschechen kolleg tschechischen
kollegen nach besten kräften den
verletzten wünschen wir schnelle
genesung
der bayerische länder bahn ist auch klar
dass es viele fragen gibt und sie hat
deshalb eine fahrgast und angehörigen
hotline geschaltet diese kontakt
rufnummer blenden wir ein
das ist die 0341 913 5 40 40 nochmal
0341 913 5 40 40 die kontakt rufnummer
für fahrgast und angehörigen fragen der
länder waren in bayern
wir wollen jetzt mit wolf christian
ulrich sprechen unserem südosteuropa
korrespondenten für tschechien sozusagen
zuständig wolf christian was ist denn
schief gelaufen jutta sagt gerade man
muss jetzt genauer untersuchen welche
knöpfe sind gedrückt worden
aber gibt es irgendwelche erkenntnisse
was schief gelaufen sein könnte ja
kasten das ist die frage habt dies ab
jetzt zu untersuchen gibt ich glaube im
büro über knöpfe reden sollte noch mal
ganz kurz revue passieren lassen wie
eigentlich der genaue hergang war
vielleicht gibt das so ein paar
anhaltspunkte
du hast es gesagt der zug sollte von
münchen nach prag fahren zum 444
losgefahren es ist ein zug der
bayerischen privaten
betreibergesellschaft länder bahn gehört
der übrigens das vielleicht noch eine
interessante neben informationen eine
tochtergesellschaft ist der staatlichen
italienischen trenitalia es gibt einem
schon so ein bisschen bild wie viele wie
aufgeteilt der zug sektor in vielen vor
allem den regionalen gebieten ja gerade
ist losgefahren kurz vor der grenze das
kennen die zuschauern und zuschauer
bestimmt auch wechselte das team das
deutsche team ging also vom board das
tschechische ging an bord damit auch der
tschechische zugführer kurz nach 8 uhr
dann auf tschechischer seite eben ein
haltesignal stand das auf gelb oder
nicht angeblich schon so der
tschechische verkehrsminister heute wir
wissen das aber noch nicht die blackbox
ist noch nicht gefunden
diese informationen sind alle nicht da
wenn man mal davon ausgeht dass sie
überfahren wurde aus welchem grund auch
immer dann passiert jetzt das was in
tschechien schon ein paar mal schief
gelaufen
es gibt viele eingleisige strecken so
auch hier der express zug fährt also auf
eine eingleisige strecke und dort
begegnet ihnen dann ein regionalzug dann
kommt es zur kollision
jetzt also die frage wie konnte das
passieren wurden köpfe nicht gedrückt
wurden signale nicht gesehen war
überhaupt der lokführer bei bewusstsein
das weiß man ja nicht also kann man auch
nicht wissen was da im cockpit oder im
vorne im zug zu der zeit los war
sicher ist es gibt für diese strecken
ein fahrdienstleiter man weiß auch nicht
zu diesem zeitpunkt was darin
informationen gekommen oder gegangen ist
und dann muss man noch mal einen sehen
die zur technik und auch die
signaltechnik wurde ja angesprochen
es ist gerade im tschechischen fernsehen
ein experte zu wort gekommen
er sagte na ja sie dürfen nicht
vergessen teilweise ist die
sicherungstechnik auf solchen strecken
und wohl auch auf dieser noch von der
jahrhundertwende 90 bis zu 20
jahrhundert und daran kann man ganz gut
sehen also bevor wir jetzt rausfinden
oder sagen was sie nun schuld ist da
gibt es so viele unterschiedliche punkte
wie es untersucht werden müssen und
hoffentlich gibt es dann mehr aufschluss
wenn die blackbox des zuges gefunden
worden ist
von christian bermes im beitrag eben
schon gehört das ist jetzt nicht das
erste unglück in jüngster zeit im
beitrag hatten wir an geschnitten dass
es letztes jahr einen unfall gab
als ein zug auf dem weg in das
sächsische johanngeorgenstadt nach der
stadt carlsberg war also die tschechisch
sächsische grenze ist da sozusagen
spielort dieses unglücks gewesen
kurze zeit später im letzten jahr gab es
ein zweites unglück in der nähe der
tschechischen hauptstadt prag passiert
das immer wieder ist das in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten ich sage mal
ganz bitter normal auf tschechischen
schienen weil wie du sagst die technik
veraltet ist oder wie muss man das
einschätzen
naja also normal sind solche unfälle
nicht denn man muss ja sehen dass
technische zug netz ist vor allem im
europäischen vergleich gesehen hat die
kollegin jutta auch eben schon gesagt
sehr groß mit 9000
streckenkilometer aber natürlich
erinnern wir uns jetzt heute an den
unfall den es vor einem jahr gegeben hat
wo ist das event nach dem erzgebirge
auch da übrigens eine eingleisige
strecke da allerdings das kann man an
dem punkt sagen war es technisches
verfahren wir wissen ja heute nicht ob
es nicht heute dieses mal ein
menschliches versagen war und dann im
vergangenen juli eine woche später nach
dem unfall im erzgebirge noch mal ein
unfall auch dort gab es einen toten zu
beklagen auch damals wenn ich das
richtig erinnere bitte nach sehen heißt
es nicht stimmt auf eingleisiger strecke
da allerdings dann menschliches versagen
also die frage ist wie kann man vor
allen dingen wenn die strecken so groß
sind denn viele unterschiedliche
gesellschaften unterwegs sind wenn vor
allen dingen viele eingleisige strecken
da sind verhindern dass es zu solchen
unfällen kommt dann müssen eigentlich
sicherheitssysteme greifen das
bekannteste und sicher ist dass der
elektronische zug steuerungs
zugsicherungssystem das ist teuer
die tschechische regierung hat zwar
versprochen jetzt der vier milliarden
euro in den kommenden 20 jahren
auszugeben um das strecken wald oder
strecken decken in tschechien
einzuführen nur wir haben jetzt 9000
streckenkilometer bis jetzt gibt es
dieses system auf 600 streckenkilometer
noch nicht mal alle wichtigsten strecken
sind damit bebaut das heißt es gibt
immer noch eine reihe von strecken die
mit alten systemen arbeiten mit alten
systemen gesichert werden müssen und man
darf auch nicht vergessen das system ist
ja nicht das eine sondern die züge
müssen dazu auch passen und einen alten
zug mit einem neuen system auszustatten
so erklären dass experten auch heute ist
nicht immer einfach
also da gibt es noch viel zu tun und das
ist natürlich für uns als nachbarn auch
deshalb relevant weil durchstechen
natürlich auch zugstrecken durchführen
in die angrenzenden länder denken sie
die strecken von berlin über prag nach
wien nach bratislava nach brünnen nach
ungarn und weiter auf ost west richtung
dann jetzt von bayern aus kommen durch
tschechien durch also es gibt eine reihe
von strecken betroffen sind sehr sehr
viel verkehr und nun wird es eben
herauszufinden sein ob es der
tschechischen regierung gelingt wirklich
ausgehen angaben einem
milliardenschweren modernisierungs
system aus diesem vorhaben dann auch
etwas konkretes zu machen so dass das
reisen etwas sicherer wird
in zukunft frisst dann stellt sich auch
die frage wie hat denn die tschechische
regierung bisher reagiert wir haben den
verkehrsminister vor ort gesehen der hat
schon auf dem weg dorthin zur
unglücksstelle gesagt die lage ist ernst
aber die regierung ministerpräsident
mappus hat er sich auch geäußert jetzt
hat airbus hat einen eintritt abgesetzt
ich könnte mir gerade vorlesen hier
moment leider ist dieser sommer voller
tragödien schreibt ministerpräsident
ball geschichte stehen in kontakt mit
dem neuen feuerwehr chef vladimir v
check der sich auf den weg gemacht haben
den familien der verstorbenen
[Musik]
aufrichtiges beileid es ist wichtig
jetzt weitere leben zu retten
anschließend muss alles untersucht
werden
also natürlich reflektiert die große
rettungsaktion die ju der sonne weitere
gerade schon detailliert beschrieben hat
zwischen technischen und mit hilfe auch
natürlich von deutschen einsatzkräften
und daneben ja jetzt muss alles
untersucht werden
toyota hat ja auch angesprochen gerade
das ist auch noch mal ein interessanter
punkt durchaus das ist in tschechien
heute eine große diskussion darüber gibt
über die belasten von lokführern es ist
ein beruf da macht man viel über stunden
der es nicht sehr beliebt sehr sehr sehr
stressig es gibt zu wenig lokführer für
die vielen strecken gefahren werden die
vielen unterschiedlichen bahnen
unternehmen auch und nun eben die frage
werden dieser mann heute man weiß das
alles nicht das ist ja alles nur
spekulation aber sollte übermüdet
gewesen sein dann wird das sicherlich
auch eine diskussion die dann auch mal
tiefer geführt werden wird aber wie
gesagt bevor wir uns jetzt hier auf
theorien verschneiten und möglichkeiten
aufführen
jetzt beginnen die untersuchungen das
wird auch eine weile dauern und dann
wird daraus sicherlich schlüsse gezogen
werden müssen für die zukunft
das ist wohl sicher richtig dass jetzt
erstmal auch die stunde ist in der man
den verletzten alles gute wünscht die
daumen drückt dass es nicht mehr
todesopfer zu beklagen gibt es vielen
vielen dank für diese informationen wolf
christian ullrich und südosteuropa
korrespondent vielen dank ja das war
unser live stream zu dem zugunglück in
tschechien nahe der bayerischen grenze
das durchaus wichtig und interessant ist
für uns
uns schon erschüttert denn wolf
christian hat es gerade gesagt das ist
eine wichtige zugverbindung von münchen
nach prag
an bord des zuges auf dem weg nach prag
auch viele deutsche und insofern werden
wir das weiter verfolgen auch unsere
beiden reporter jutta sonne wald direkt
vor ort am unglücksort als auch wolf
christian ulrich was ursachen angeht wie
aber auch die rettung weitergeht wir
danken ganz herzlich für ihr interesse
sagen tschüss auf wiedersehen und einen
schönen tag noch